and go very quickly to the emergency
operation announcement wind Simic room
for motion you can see evacuation
announcement should we be required to in
fact we've built in which please leave
the building by the nearest available
exit there is one product see in this
room you need to evacuate the room do so
by the glass door please hold both
handrails in case it stands on wet or
slippery anyone that is unable to use
the stairs would they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape door where they can
be given assistance our somebody point
will be in the public power park at the
scientific suite please do not delay
your evacuation flips any belonging
please do not return through the
building I give you permission to do so
by council staff please let this meeting
will be audio recorded and I remind you
to switch off your mobile phones thank
you okay first of all apologies for
absence councillor butch in hippie yeah
but I've got a substitute counselor mrs.
Weston non-members attending sorry
welcome it's enjoy to number four
minutes of the meeting held on the 20th
of June 2019
so anybody got anything they would like
to arrange from the minutes
um none of the freezers are true
Michaels green thank you see how the
grief of them agenda item number 5 to
receive declarations of interest other
earning and agenda item number 6 local
investigation into terminations from
April to September 2019 there's a
summary of complaints and queries
received relations brokers get a job in
the private combats every bit above that
and it is just amazing that noted
everyone
okay the meeting is now officially
closed and meeting last night so when I
said chairman mrs. Mason would you like
to hit the purple no will report the
next problem eating
okay that's lovely thank you and that
will be certainly will be agenda and
that will be circulated and bye